hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from the 1963 u.s. championship between
Bobby Fischer and pal Benko
benka a very strong grandmaster and the
guy behind the opening we know today the
Benko gambit was unfortunately no match
for Fischer in fact in this tournament
Fischer played 11 games and won all 11
games an incredible feat no doubt and in
this round 10 game Fischer played simply
and finished up with the beautiful
combination one which had been Coe 21
moves in throwing in the towel so let's
have a look and see how this game played
out Fischer opening up with E 4 in Benko
opting for a modern defense g6 the
modern defense in summary is allowing
for white to build a center only to
later try and take it down so that's
exactly what we see by white white
builds the center has efore and d4 in
Bishop g7 Knight c3 d6 so with the d6
black will be looking to try and take it
down with either c5 or a 5 in both
instances this Bishop is influenced this
Bishop will increase in mobility in some
way so we're also seeing a reason for
white delaying this King knight's
development to that f3 square because
with move for f4 white is going forward
with an Austrian attack having these
three puns are trying to use these three
pawns right here as a spearhead for some
attack against that black King after
Knight f6 Knight f3 black castles Bishop
d3 this right here it seems like if
white is gonna be going for an attack it
seems like Bishop c4 would be the mood
to be going with because it's you know
opposite that plac King but it's not
without its problem because black has a
small combination that could be used to
obtain and to obtain what I feel is a
perfectly playable position right here
we could see 97 to f6 and then moves
like b6 Bishop e7 I think Black has a
perfectly playable game and has
certainly been successful in breaking up
those three pawns so maybe that's a
reason for not playing this Bishop to
the more aggressive looking
see for square instead Bishop d3
and Bishop g4 which is a big decision on
blacks Park because Bishop g4 is played
with the intention of giving itself up
for the night
many times in chess you'll see a move
like Bishop g4 played and then after
your opponent maybe responds with h3
maybe the bishop would then come back or
something and maybe try and make use of
the now weakened let's say g3 square but
in this case that's not going to happen
g3 would not be something that is
accessible really to the black pieces
and another thing to question is is the
time spent in making those two moves
with the bishop really worth it and in
this case it wouldn't be and so that's
why I'm saying Bishop g4 really is
played with the intention of giving it
up giving itself up for the night and
that's exactly what we see as soon as
white puts a question to it h3 we have
an exchange on f3 and as a direct
consequence of not having the Knight d4
is weakened and so black develops with
tempo but unfortunately it's not an
inconvenience to white light similarly
develops only with defense of that d4
square so black persists with E 5
putting another question to that d4
square and after de de
we have f5 and unfortunately for black
they're in a very difficult position I
believe already because there's a very
strong possibility that if black doesn't
act fast this Jeep on can be thrown up
to that g4 square and once it gets to
that point there's a ton of
possibilities really let me just point
out life night d4 let's just do a quick
hypothetical if we had 94 Queen goes
back and then c6 something that you know
a move which is a bit purposeful right
it's taking away that deef d5 post from
the c3 Knight we could have g4 and
already white I believe is threatening
to win the game in some sense because
let's just make a random move like Queen
c7 we're going to have moves
like this and this Bishop gets the door
slammed in its face it's stuck on h8 for
the remainder of the game there's no
breaking down the structure and so
things are certainly very critical right
away and so there's well there's even
the option after g4 is played if black
now thinks about taking on f5 it's not
without allowing the G Brooks and
play-along this G file certainly this
white King has not yet committed itself
and white is having a ready-made attack
along this newly opened file so maybe
these are a couple of the reasons behind
Benko opting to just take on f5 first so
after Queen takes on F 594 hitting the
Queen so it's a centralizing move
hitting the Queen but she just calmly
comes back to f2 and everything is quite
alright keeping a close eye indirectly
on that d4 square after night I ate the
knight is just looking to reposition
you'll see that many times in a chess
game the knight will retreat to in order
to just you know look for a more useful
square and d6 is one which is seemingly
more useful it's going to stay out of
the way of this pond and be supporting
potentially its advance which is
something that I don't know that I could
really recommend because it's just
allowing for this light square bishop to
then show itself in the position but
unfortunately black is in a very
difficult position already so a white
fully develops at this point that's
indicated by a direct connection between
these white rooks after ninety six we
now see the Queen slowly inching her way
towards the black King and with the
first move it comes with a very serious
threat of now Bishop h6 since this
bishop is now pinned to the king
so black avoids that threat with King h8
Queen g4 trying to get the Queen to this
hole in the black position that h5
square the jeep on for black is absent
and so a direct consequence is that the
squares on the H file are all going to
be weakened points and the Queen is
trying to access h5 because
there's a very cunning idea that white
has so an additional reason for this
Queens placement might have been to just
keep a close eye on f5 in the event
black really did want to play that move
well it's not going to be allowed at
this point not at least without the loss
of material so at this point we see c6 a
very purposeful seemingly you know just
taking away that d5 square from the
night but after Queen h5 and Queen to e8
we see black unfortunately on the wrong
end of a spectacular combination Bishop
takes Knight pawn takes Bishop and now
rook to f6 what in the world is going on
with this well here's what it is if
Bishop takes rook c5 in this Bishop
which looked earlier like it was just
doing nothing but staring at upon all of
a sudden comes to life and there's no
way to prevent made on h7 there's only
one way to delay the inevitable and
that's with just doing computer-like
moves delaying the threat of mate with
moves like Knight e4 or Knight to f5 and
so the game would end very quickly if
the rook was taken but in this in this
game
unfortunately it ends soon enough we see
h6 and then just be 5 again just
clearing the way for this Bishop to show
itself in the position again there's no
taking the rook because of a mate in two
and after blacks next move King to g8
because the other threat at this point
is just to crash through on h6 width
check so the king is unfortunately
having to go back to that g8 Square King
g8 and now light calmly just retreats
there Knight and with this the next with
this move right here black is
unfortunately having to resign because
this rook is still immune from capture
Bishop takes rook would allow for Queen
takes pawn and mate will be coming up
right away on that h7 square and the
other threat at this point is to this
Knight if this rook can't be captured
right now that means that this Knight is
having to move
and as soon as it moves the Queen can
make use of this f5 square again getting
ready to go to that h7 square but as it
happened in this game after a simple
retreat move Knight to e2 Benko resigns
so that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye